サッブパッパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ
サチッッタパリオダパナン エタングブッダナサーサナン
はい 今年も幸福な年でありますようにと
まず祝福をいたします
で 私たちブッダお釈迦様の教えを学ぶ人々には
特別なお守りとかは全く要りません
生命のお守りというのは
たった唯一たった一つ
それは慈しみの気持ちなんですね
ですから 今日から皆様方は朝晩
何か始まる時 いつでも思い浮かんだ時
慈悲の瞑想を言葉を念じて
これこそ自分のお守りだと
すべて問題 トラブル いろいろ乗り越えて
物事はかなりスムーズに流れる方法であるとね
思って 毎日慈悲の瞑想をお守りにもしてください
この瞑想は瞑想ですけど
それが人々を 生命を守ってくれるんですね
いつでもお釈迦様の言葉は
真理を実践する人は真理が守ってあげているんだと
そういうことだから 特別にこの迷信的ないろいろなお守りなどは全くいらないんですね
みんな方法を間違っているだけで
そういうことで 皆様にまずと人生の究極の幸福のお守りとして
慈悲の瞑想があるので
それを実行してみてください
では 今日のお話に入りますが
どうももう かなり難しいテーマになっているんですね
これ テーマ考えている人はすごい楽ちんだと思ったでしょうが
もう私にとってはこれ
かなりきつい かなり量が多い
データの量も説明も結構ややこしい話なんですね
一応我々一般人として
いろんな意見がある中で
どちらが正しいか どちらが本物かということを知りたくはありますね
この気持ちはとてもシンプルなんですが
このやり方はとても難しいんです
この考えが間違って この考えが正しいというのは
もうとっても難しいんです
それに理由があるんです
私たちの思考 あるいは脳
どちらでもいいんだけど
この 2 次元で働くんですね Yes
かノーか で とにかくこの脳にはやるかやらないか
どちらかしなくちゃあかんですよ
だからこの皆様 曖昧中途半端かもしれませんだけど
脳にとってはそれすっごい悪い状態な状態なんです
私たちは気持ち的に曖昧
中途半端でいる そのつもりだけなんです
脳がやっぱりそれでも判断して活動するんで
この中途半端っていうのは
やるかやらないかと決めたところでやらないという判断なんです
やらない その代わりに悩むと
それは中途半端な状態なんで
脳には中途半端状態がないんです
やるかやらないか Yes
かノーか あるかないか
どちらかなんです そこでこのいろんなアイデアについても
これどちらにしようかなと
よくわからないなという状態になってくると
かなり我々は精神的にもう苦しむんです
これ感じないかもしれませんだけど
この精神エネルギーがすごく浪費してなくなってしまうんです
結果としてすごい無知なろくでもない人間になってしまうんです
もう悪いことをしてろくでもない人間になったって
もう格好いいんですよ
何もやってないんですよ
どうしようか どうしようか
この意見かあの意見か
この困った困ったとかね
これがかなり自分の精神的な力がなくなってしまうことになりますから
気をつけましょう 人間が喜んじゃって悪いことをしてしまっちゃってね
人生はダメになったとしても
まあある程度で本人が私やっちゃったんだからしょうがないよというふうなね
まあしっかりすることはできますよ
非難されたっても仕方がない
まあだって私はこういうことを生き方したんだからとかね
まあその程度の落ち着きもなくなっちゃうんですね
悪い方の落ち着きでもね
ですから このだから問題なんです
脳にとっては癒やしか否か
どちらか知りたいんですね
でもなんかよくわからなくなっちゃうんですね
で そこはお釈迦様は彼の心育てる場合は
このウッダッチャという言葉を使ってます
上戸 とても危険な悪い心情なんです
このウッダッチャっていうのは
日本語でいうファジーで曖昧で中途半端で
という状態なんですね
これはもう心成長する場合は決してあってはならないことなんです
あってはならないというのは簡単だけど
ある場合はどうしますかなんですね
だからそれは物事を正しく考える
理解する いわゆる客観的に物事を見るという能力を育てることで
この中途半端が消えていくんですね
この中途半端精神がある限りは
この瞑想なんかしたっても全然進まないんです
もう最初の一歩で止まるんです
そういうわけで ウッダッチャという状況に気をつけましょう
はい では順番で考えておきましょう
ちょっと内容は難しいかもしれませんだけど
まあ頑張ってください
生命と認識機能 生命とは認識能力を持っている組織です
ここから皆様 新たに考えてください
この全く迷信 信仰を捨てて
科学的に 生命っていうのは組織なんですね
いろんな組織が世の中にあります
組織ってシステムですから
英語で言えばね この音声も組織でしょ
みんなに聞こえるような音声システム
で サウンドシステムと言ってるんだから
だからいろんな部品 パート
いろんな機能が組み立てたところで
私が喋る音が大きくして出してくれるんです
これ一つの組織なんです
政府っていうのは一つの組織なんですね
だから世の中にあるものはすべて組織
組織 組織でできているんです
こちらにあるこの花もそうなんです
花が 1本1本 一輪一輪組織であって
組み立てたところでまた組織であって
そういうまたいろんなものを入れていますから
その中でいろんな組織ができているんですね
だから世の中っていうのはいつでもこの何かしら組織なんです
組織でないものはないんです
これはありえないんです
まあ例えば元素なんかどうですか？と
組織ですよ 組織で安定するんです
例えば原子の核が自由にいられますか？自由にはいられません
周りにはまあ何だらかんだらまたエネルギーを回ってくれないと
エレクトロンというね
だからエレクトロンのエネルギーの場が現れてね
そのその中で核が一応安定していると
でも一個ではなかなか不安定だから
また他の他の原子とつなげて組織になっているんです
だからまあ すべてのもの事はそうやって組織なんですね
それで生命っていうのは認識機能が入っている組織なんですね
マイクロフォンには この音声システムには認識機能がないんです
こちらにあるこの組織には認識機能があります
それだけ だから生命というし
それについて まあいろんな意見が世の中で無数にあるんです
生き続ける目的を達成するために物事を認識します
次のポイント なんで音声システムが何も認識しないのに
組織ができたんだから
私がこちらに空気を振動させると
そこに反応して音を拡大してくれますけど
認識機能はないんです
それでこの組織が認識機能を持っています
しかし 音声システムとこちらの場合は違うところがあるんです
私が生きていきたいんですね
死にたくはない このマイクロフォン
初めからある この音声システムにはその気持ちはありません
壊れたくない 故障したくないはないんです
もうこちら剥がれてますけどね
マイクロフォンの色は
そういう気持ち何にもないんです
そこは違うところなんです
ある組織が存続したいんですね
インスタンツオブサバイバルなんです
それで我々は何で物事を認識しますか？というと
存続するためなんです
否定的な言葉で言えば死なないためなんです
で 死なないということはそんなにもう大した言葉ではありません
なぜならば 今はそこを経験していないんだからね
今我々が経験しているのは生きていきたいということで
そこで生きていきたいと生きていられるならば思う必要ないでしょ
そこで あ もしかすると生きていられないかもということが出てくるんです
だから生きていきたいと思っているんです
こういうのは人の好みと関係なく
システムそうだから システムは出来上がったとこからも成り立たないという特色があるんです
壊れる どんなシステムのもう本質は壊れることなんです
だって無理やりつなげたもんだからね
まあ無理やりでもないんだけどね
つなげるもの つなげられるものはつながりますからね
でも壊れ 壊れていくんですね
そこで生命組織がそれ認識するんです
知ってるんです それですごい衝動が生まれてくるんですね
生きていきたいという
それは単細胞の生命も同じなんです
単細胞の生命はたくさんあるんだけど
いろんな種類ね みんな存続したいという気持ちが持っているんです
それは考えではないんです
人間みたいにごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃ考えることは要りません
だから心が考えるものだと言ったら
それは間違いなんです
単細胞は存続したいんですよ
だからその気持ちが心なんですね
ですから認識はしているんです
我々人間が使っている認識という大胆な意味じゃないんですけどね
だから私は違う言葉を使うんです
感じる という そうすると認識みたいな派手な単語はいらなくなっちゃいますね
アミバさんが考えているかというと
考えていないでしょう
単細胞のね 脳細胞何もないしね
でも感じるということはあるんですね
そこで私たちは 40兆の感じる単位を組織にしているんですよ
40兆の細胞が感じるものだから
そこはさらにさらにいろんなことに変化して
認識する 考える あれやこれやと現れてくるんです
だから大本は感じることなんです
すべての認識は存在欲に関わるものです
というわけで 生命を持っている一切の認識は
存在欲に何かしら関係あるんです
何かしら関係あると言ったっても
本当は存続したいなというところで認識しているんです
ですから 私が知っているすべてのことは
私の存在に関わるものに限るということになるんです
そこでかなり難しいポイントですけど
で これは本当にお釈迦様は昔ね
すごい革命的なアイデアを出してるんです
人ではなくて 仏教は生命という言葉を使うんだから
生命の知ってる世界は何ですか
この生命がたとえ神であっても
悪魔であっても どうでもいいんです
仏教には 生命が知っている世界は
その生命の存続に関わるものです
それでわかりますかね
大したことないんだと
ね 我々知ってる世界っていうのは大したことない
この私は知ってる世界は
これどうやって生き続けていくかって
その程度で終わっているんです
これ誤解しないでください
私たちはそうじゃない
人のことも考えてますよとか
考えてますよ それはあなたの生命存続に関係あるんだからね
私の生き方に関係ないものは考えてないんです
いや 家族のことも考えても考えてますよ
家族のことも だってそれはあなたに関係あるんだから
そういうことなんです
いえいえ 細菌のことも考えてますよと考えてますよ
だって細菌感染したら病気になるんだからね
だからマイクロバイオロジーを勉強しますよ
というわけで 知ってる世界はすべて存在
私の存在に関わる 私の存在っていうことが大事です
なぜならば この組織が知るんだからね
私っていうのはただ言葉ですけど
組織なんですね この組織の存続に関わる知識なんですね
というわけで 事実は優先ではありません
物事を知ってますけど
これ事実か嘘かとは本当は関係ないんです
私は生きられるかないかだけなんです
だから生きられるために嘘は派手に使ってますよ
結構人間ってのは占い信じてるでしょ
無数に占いの手相占い
あれやこれやとかあるでしょ
あれは完全嘘ですけど
信じてますよ なぜならば
占い師がこれあれやこれやこれやと言われると
なんとなく勇気が出てくるんです
だから 世の中にあるどんな占い師も言ってることは同じなんで
大丈夫です まああとまあもう問題あるんだから占いするでしょ
だからいたって簡単ですね
私が何か悩んで悩んで問題があって心配があると
占い師のところに行く
行って占ってもらう だから占い師にとってはテーマが簡単です
こいつは何かトラブってるんだと
今頃ね まあちょこちょこっていろいろ問題あるそうで
まあそれも顔を見て年齢見てわかりますからね
だいたい占い師に行くのはほとんど女の子だからね
もうあの連中で経済成り立ってますからね
だからアホっていうのはすごくいいんですよ
経済は成り立つのです
で だからまああんたね
男運が今頃ちょっともうないんですよと
あと半年経ったらなんとか言ってくれる
それは気分がいいんです
で まあ男性が言ったら
まあ男の子が言ったら
もう若者だったら まあそれ問題なく
異性の問題で もう友達がいないということで
それに合わせてアドバイスすればいいんです
社会人の若者が言ったら
確実に仕事のトラブルうまくいってない
そうやって占い師にとっては占いをするということは至って簡単なんですね
それに何かインチキ ごまかし使う
紅茶占い コーヒー占い
手相占い もう運勢 なんとか星座占いとか
なんだらかんだらとか
それはすべて嘘ですけど
しかし なんでこの世間で科学世界でそういう非科学的なものがあるのかというと
存在欲に関わるがあるんですね
ちょっと勇気付けてくれるんです
なんとか慰めてくれるんです
そういうわけで 私たちにとっては事実か否かは関係ないんです
生きることを支えてくれるかだけなんです
支えてくれるならば そちらに飛びかかる
生きることを支えてくれないんだったら
無関心になる 例えば皆様
今日から明日からでもいいんだから
スワヒリ語を勉強してくださいって言ったらやる？やらないね
なんで？何に関何の関係もないよと
役に立ったんでしょ だから知識は結局はそんなもんなんですよ
存続に関わるものなんです
この存在欲を支えるもの
存在に危害を与えるもののみが
子に対して事実です 真理です
だから私たちは科学者でも何でもないんです
生命は科学者もそうなんです
科学者も科学者じゃないんです
だから この存在欲を支えてくれるか
あるいは存在に危害を与えるものか
このどちらが調べているだけ
それで私たちはそれが真理ですと
と信じ込んでいるんです
だから皆様 今日からね
すごく自由になってください
私はこの心を解放するために
この話をしているんです
そんなにこのテーマは難しいんだけど
皆様に今日紹介するセクションはすごい簡単
軽いところなんです こんな意見にそんなしがみつかなくてもいいんです
自分の意見も大したことないんです
これ 生きられるかないかだけの話なんです
私たちにとっては 地球が丸かろうと四角い
もうもうどんな形であろうが関係ないんですよ
だからそれも存続に関わる
昔 地球が丸いと発見した方々にしても
教会があまりも狂暴で人々に迷惑をかけていたんだから
自分たちだけ権力を取って
他の生命にはもう何の自由も平等も何もない
搾取されていたんですね
それになると 搾取される側にとっては存在欲には問題あるんですね
それで調べたんですね
調べたら もう神が空と土を作ったんじゃなくて
これ丸いものやと で 発見しちゃうんです
もう大地中心に星が回ってるんじゃなくて
もう地球が回ってるんだと
で そこで人間が自由を獲得するんですね
だから搾取されることがいくらかなくなったんですね
だから その意見に今飛びかかっているんです
それで調べたら本当に地球が丸いんですが
まあだからといって別に関係ないでしょ
生きる場合は それ生きる前は関係ないことなんです
ね 他の子に別なデータが事実になります
それでポイントは 私が知ってる世界は私にとって真理です
他の人が知ってる世界は
その人にとって真理です
でしょ ゴキブリさんが知ってる世界は
ゴキブリさんにとっては真理です
その環境が変わると ゴキブリさんは死んじゃいます
人間が存続するために必要な環境をゴキブリさんが覚えておけば
そいつは死にます それは嘘です
明るいところがよしと我々思ってるでしょ？ゴキブリさんはとんでもない話やと
嘘やと 暗いところはよしと
だから暗いところは良い
生活するためには良いというのはゴキブリさんの真理です
明るいところが生活するために必要だというのは人間の真理です
そこで夜 夜行性の鳥たちがいるんですね
そちらの真理はまた違うんです
例えばコウモリにしても
光はそんなに関係あるものじゃないんです
だから明るくなければダメや
生きていられないやという
光が大事なものだという考えはないんです
ね 人間と昼活動する生命に対しては
光は神様ですよ もう光ってくれるんだから
だって光を拝むでしょ
初めはね どんな人間も太陽を拝んでいたでしょ
神になっていたんです
日本は今もその習慣ありますけどね
他の国々ではその習慣は消えてまして
でもインドではそれなりにはあるんです
インドのヒンドゥー教では
太陽信仰 シューリデーヴァターというんですね
車があるんです 車で乗っていくんです
光っているのは車の車輪なんです
だってつ欲しいんだけど
車輪だったらね 一個しかないんですけど
神のことだから余計なことを聞くなよなんです
それでまああの 私は英語で言うならば
ノレッジイズエクストリームリーパーソナル
知識 知る世界はエクストリームリー極端的にパーソナル個人的です
それから それがサバイバル存続のためのノレッジなんです
だから 私に存在できる環境と他の生命に存在できる環境が違いますから
それぞれ知識が変わっていくんです
事実 真理に真理は個によって変わるもので
似ている必要も同じものになる必要もありません
でしょ？難しくないね
真理だからみんな同じことを信じなくちゃあかんとか
そんなことどうでもいいんです
私が自分勝手に真理と言っているんであって
他の人はその人の勝手で真理だと言っているだけなんです
似ている必要はないんです
ここで人間が間違いを犯すんですね
だから今まで言ったことは人間知らないんです
自分が知っている世界は正しいと言っているだけでね
ここで間違いを犯すんです
当然 意見見解が無双です 100
人いたら100種類です
1億だったら1億種類です
地球上の生命はどれぐらいいるんですかね？それぐらい喧嘩やるんです
アリ塚の中でもアリ みんな同じ気持ちで生きてると思いますか？そうじゃないんです
それぞれアリの生き方は違うんです
ミツバチにいたっても
一匹一匹の生き方は違うんです
だからそれぞれの意見持ってますよ
意見といえば 脳細胞を持ってる連中ばっかりですけど
やっぱり気持ちを持ってるんです
地になってます しかし
自分にとっては自分の意見
また打ち間違いあります
自分の意見だけが正しいんです
まあいくつか間違いありますけど
まあ頭の中で直して しかし
自分にとっては自分の意見だけが正しいんです
では  100億の生命が 100億種類の意見を持ってるんだけど
一人一人の生命が自分の意見だけ正しいと思っているんです
ある面で仕方がない それなんです
例えば まあ昆虫はとてもいい
おいしい食べ物やと思っている人間がいる
でも私たちはあんまり昆虫は食べるものだと思わないんですね
食べたくはないんです
だから昆虫食べる人間がアリ食べる場合もあるしね
まあびっくりしましたけど
タイでね もうこの赤いアリがいるんですよ
ファイアーアンツというんでね
噛んだらすごい痛いんですね
あれ 酢の成分を持ってるんですね
アシティックアシッドというものが
そこはちょっと ちょっと皮膚を微妙に傷つけて
あのアシティックアシッド入れるんで
痛いんですよ でも毒じゃないんですよ
酢っていうのは あの その酸ですからね
で 大臣がこれ酸っぱくて美味しいやと思って
あれ そのファイア ant スカー
そのまま破って 全部卵全部落としてもらって
あのお粥に入れてもらって食べてるんですね
まあ酸っぱく酸っぱくて美味しいでしょうと思いますけど
食べたくはないんです
それで昆虫を食べる人々もいますよ
だから昆虫を食べる人間にとってはそれが事実で美味しい食べ物で
これこそ食べ物やと言うんですね
それで日本人も言ってるでしょ
和食こそ世界一番美味しいものやと
そう思っているんです
それで昆虫を食べる人に和食を食べさせてみてください
え？と言うかもしれません
なんだこりゃと そんなのはそんなもんです
だから正しいというのは
この個体を維持管理できるデータなんです
そこで我々の間違いは何なのかというと
これも自然の流れである間違いだから
あの神様を裏切ったんだから
人間が アダムとイーブがね
神様に逆らったんだから
すべての生命は罪人だというくだらない話じゃないんです
生命は誰のことも裏切ったわけじゃないんです
人間が生まれつき罪人やっていうのは
キリスト教文化の話なんです
それちょっとおかしいんです
人間に限らず どんな生命も誰も裏切ったわけじゃないんです
生きるためにいろんなデータを取り寄せて認識する
認識できない生命は感じる
考えることできる我々は考えることまでする
哺乳類の生命には脳があるんだから
言葉で考えないんだけど
いろいろ概念は持って
それなりに概念を組み合わせてはいる
脳システムができていない生命は感じて生きている
その時はもうこれが事実
これが事実という世界が現れてくるんです
だから存続に関わるものなんです
そこで自分を生かしてくれる知識は正しいと思っちゃうでしょ
それ正しいと思っちゃうんです
我々はパイナップルを食べるならば
皮を剥いて中身食べるべきやと思っている
それは事実で真理です
我々にとっては 試しに皮を食べてみたら
ものすごい大変なことになります
日本のパイナップル かなりいろんな薬で洗っていろいろしていますから
食べてもちょっと口の中で微妙に怪我するだけで終わりますけどね
自然に取ったものはやっぱり口に入れるものじゃないんです
いろんな成分 皮に入っているんです
しかし 牛 ヤギは皮がおいしそうに食べているんです
ゾウさんにパイナップルをあげたら
全然皮剥かないんです
そのまま口の中に入れちゃうんです
これだけじゃなくて パイナップルあげをすると
ちょっと遅くなっちゃうと早く出せと鼻を出して取っちゃうんです
これゾウさん力強いんだから
ある程度でちょっとやばいんです
別に攻撃されているわけないんだけど
もう引っ張っちゃうと人間に力がないんだからね
というわけで 誰か裏切ってるんです
我々はパイナップルの皮は食べるものじゃないって考えてるだけ
それは事実やと言ってることで
誰のことも裏切ってないんです
誰のことも冒涜してないんです
それはこういう組織の場合は仕方がないんです
人間はフグを食べる場合は
肝は決して食べてはいけないと思ってるんです
食べたら死んじゃいますからね
私は知らないんだけど
これはもういろいろテレビから得た知識ですからね
私がフグの肝も食べられる生命がいると思いますよ
だって共食い世界だからね
魚たちの世界は だからフグを食べる魚がいるならば
そのまま丸飲みして食べるでしょ
だから死んじゃったら困るでしょうに
だからわかりません でも人間がフグを食べようと思ったところで
肝は美味しそうに見えるんだけど
これが食べられないと発見したんです
だからフグの身の方だけ食べるべきだということを人間が知っています
それは事実ですね それは人間にとって真理です
フグ食べるの日本人だからね
それで皆様 誰か裏切ってるんですかね
誰か冒涜していますかね
神に逆らってるんですかね
じゃないでしょ そんなのは自然の流れ
そこで我々が起こす間違いも
神を冒涜する間違いではなくて
当然ながら起こってしまう間違いなんです
それは何だというと 私の意見が正しいということなんです
相手の違う意見を認めることも
受け入れることも 理解することも難しいんです
ちょっと理解できない
認めるわけにはいきません
例えば 母親が子供たち
自分の子供が言っている意見には
まあ認めない 賛成しないということはいっぱいあるんです
子供たちが母親の考え方で認めない
理解できないものはいっぱいあるんです
あるでしょ 時にお父さんは全然もうわかりそうで
私の気持ちをわかってん
わかるわけないでしょうに
と そこは難しいんですね
人の気持ち 人の意見 認めること難しいし
理解すること難しいし
受け入れることも難しいです
例えば 一人の若者が引きこもりになっちゃって
もう私は外へ出たくない
もうもうすごい あれやこれやとかね
社会は怖い 会社 学校などなど行きたくはない
それで部屋に閉じこもった引きこもっているんです
本人が それが正しいと思っているでしょ
しかし 両親にとってはその意見は受け入れられる
受け入れられないんです
あ そうかそうかと そこでまあいろいろまあ置きますよ
自分の意見に固執するし
他人に自分の意見を押し付けようともするし
他人の意見を潰そうともするのです
そこなんです 問題は 引きこもりの人は
人間社会に取り戻すために頑張るのはいいんだけど
だから一般論で考えれば
引きこもりは存続に関わるものじゃなくて
存続を否定するものなんです
人間が引きこもりになったらどうなるんですかね
人類に生きていられなくなりますね
だからそこで我々人間同士でなんとか意見
何て言いますか コンプロマイズですね
なんとかもう意見を作ることはできます
だから 自分の子供が引きこもりだったら
それを何とかして直す努力は一向に構いません
しかし 世の中である危険なことは
自分の意見に固執する
仏教が意見について語る場合は
問題にするのはこの固執の問題なんです
しがみつくことの問題なんです
たったワンポイントです
お釈迦様が言っているのは
意見に対してうんうんと言わない
アリ食べている人にとっては何も言いません
アリがアリを食べるなよとかね
アリはかわいそうでしょうとか言ったってバカバカしいでしょうね
アリ食べないでチゲン食べたっても
ニワトリさんがかわいそうだからね
そんな変なことは言いません
アリ食べたら体に悪いよと言います
だってその連中はそれを食べて元気でいるんだから
だから問題は固執するなよと
世界一ごちそうはファイアアンツに限るやと言うなよと
食べるアリの名前は英語でファイアアンツなんですね
だからゴキブリを食べる人間いるかもよ
まあ勝手にしなさいなんですよ
だから仏教いうのは その意見に固執するなよと
ご飯をお茶わて手で握っちゃって
海苔を貼って食べるのは構いませんだけど
それこそ世界一美味しいごちそうだって
そんなそこだけやめてくださいと
意見にケチつけてないんです
仏教は何にケチつけるのかというと
何に固執することに なぜならば
他の人々は別な意見を持っている
その人々もそれなりの理由があって
そこを固守しているんです
あの乾季の時 食べ物なくなると
人間も皮の木の皮まで食べるんです
あれ あんまり食べるものではないんだけど
飢えているんだから 日本の鹿は冬になってくると
全部皮 木の皮をね かぎ取って食べているんです
植物は死にますけど それで
鹿にとっても葉っぱ食べた方がいいんだけどね
なければどうしますかね
というわけで 何か理由があって何か意見を作るんですが
その意見に固執してはいけません
それだけで今日の話のすべてのテーマは
結論は 英語で言うならば
the greatest problem is not the view itself, but the deep
attachment to one's
personal views
はい そういうことで この世の中で個体と意見の種類が同じですね
ほぼ同じ 本当は意見の方がもっとたくさんですけどもね
100人いれば意見 100種類じゃないんです
何万種類もあるんです
まあ一応大雑把で まあ個体と個体の数と意見の数が同じだとしてください
その中で似ている意見がある
ちょっと違う意見がある
正反対の意見もある だからアイデンティカルビューズ
ディファレントビューズ
アンドコントラディクトリービューズという 3種類が出てくるんです
それ理解しましょう 似ている意見
ちょっと違う意見 正反対の意見
あるんです はい ちょっと飛ばしましょう
哲学と宗教って何なのか
これ 意見の世界でしょ
で 私はこのすごい勢いで作っちゃったんだから
まだまだ まあ本当は中は半分英語ですよ
まだ日本語を通して生まれていないんですけど
存続するための認識ですが
他を他の死を経験すると認識は揺らぎます
私は存続するために物事を知ろう知ろう知ろうとしているんです
そうすると余計なデータが入るんですね
生命の死を 考えなくちゃいけないんですよ
それは存続に関わらあるんです
自分の家族の誰か死んじゃうと
自分の存続にそれすごい影響あるんです
例えば あの人が川に落ちて死んだというと
知らない人だから関係ないではないんです
もしかすると自分も川で不調になったらということはあるでしょうに
だから日本で原発が壊れた時は
まあ周りいろいろところで
他の国々もこうちょっとね
品物は輸入しないとかいろいろあったんでしょうに
関係ないでしょ ではないんですね
ですから 生命が死ぬことは
やっぱり気になる 大いに気になる
なぜならば 私は死なないために物事を知っているんです
そういうわけで 死は認識を揺らぐんです
あんた知ってること本当に正しいと自分を疑いの目で見る羽目になるんです
自分知ってる世界は あら
これで大丈夫かなと まあ例えばある人が納豆とご飯を食べているんですね
健康にいいんだからという
納豆とご飯を食べたら
もう体すごく健康になっちゃって
ガンなんかはにはなりませんと
いろんなくずらんことみんな食べてますよ
がんにならないとか がんが治るとかね
それで同じものを食べている人ががんになったと聞いた途端どうなる？自分今までの生き方
すぐ揺らぎ揺らいでしまいますね
だから我々 この毎日やっていることなんですけど
深い心理ありますよ だから皆様に仏教が必要なんですよ
だからこのすべてのからくりを教えてくれるんだから
人間の知識はなんで揺らぐんですかね
こういう理由なんです
死を認識しなくちゃあかんですね
人の病気などなどを認識しなくちゃあかんですよ
脳出血になったり 心臓発作を起こしたり
糖尿病になったり 生活習慣病になったり
あれこれやといらんでったの方に入るんですね
本当は私の隣の人は脳出血で倒れたんだからって
私の存在に関係ないんだけど
やっぱり関係あるんですね
あれ これはやばいと もしかすると私の生き方
私の生活習慣 本当にそれでいいんですかと
私も脳出血になったらやばいやと思うでしょ？だから関係ない人の脳出血も
自分の認識システムを揺らぐようになるんです
それで疑が生じるんです
これは仏教で瞑想する人々に教える五蓋の話なんです
なんで心は清澄成長しないのかと
疑ということが心に生じるんです
疑ってまずいでしょう
知る世界に疑が入っちゃうと
知らないことになるんです
死を認める能力がない
私の細胞たちに死を認めましょうという能力はもう初めからもないんです
あったらこんなくだらんことをやらんでしょ？生きてやるぞ
生きてやるぞと 放っておけということになるんです
だから死を認める能力がないんです
細胞にもないし 脳細胞にもないし
細胞は死ぬことは知らないんだけど
脳細胞はやっぱりはっきり概念として知るということを知っているんです
大脳の方 あの脳幹は知らないんです
死を認める能力がないので
自分の知識を改良しようとするんです
こんなバカなことをやるんです
知識を変えようと 知識に問題あるんだと
言ってみれば知識に問題あるんだけど
この改良する方法は何なのかと
哲学文化と宗教文化が現れるんです
とんでもないことをやっちゃうんです
この場合も当然多数の意見が現れます
これ 哲学者はこの魂のことを初めは哲学したんです
宗教も魂 霊魂という妄想概念取り入れちゃって
この死をごまかそうとするんです
これは知識改良じゃないんです
知識は揺らぎったんです
揺らいだんです 揺らぎったではなくて
知識は揺らいでのは構いませんよ
そこで あら 私が真理だと思っていたのに
私は私の意見に固執していたのに
揺らいでいるんですね
傲岸が生まれて何とかしなくてはと思って
魂やら霊魂やら天国やら
いろんな概念を作るんです
そこでまた同じ問題 これ子が作る思考でしょ
ですから 世の中で宗教たくさん
当然哲学がたくさん 一歩上にはならないんです
だからその時点で宗教間違っているとこ見えるはずなんです
だって唯一の神がいるんだ
いるならば 地球人類みんなその唯一の化け物を信仰するでしょうに
そうじゃないでしょうに
唯一の神もいっぱいいるんです
日本でも大川隆法が自分が神だと思っているんです
だから現在 我々に経験できるケースがあるんだから
当然頭がいかれているということがわかるでしょ
だったら昔の連中も頭がいかれていたんです
神を作った人々 新たな争いが成り立ちます
そこで今も我々は喧嘩しているのに
人の意見違いでね 私の意見正しいよ
あなた何考えているのかとかね
考え方改めなさいよとかね
もうえらい喧嘩やってますよ
例えば北朝鮮はなんか水爆作ったことを正しいと思っていて
世界は間違っていると思って
もうすごい怒ってるんですね
そういうふうに世の中でいろんなことについて争いがあるんですよ
そこで人は死ぬっていうことは
経験した人間が宗教 哲学を作って
宗教 哲学の中で争いがまた生まれてきたんです
あれは日本語で書いてないんだけど
私はメモで英語で書いてありますけどね
イモータルという概念を作ったんですね
イモータルって何でしたっけ
まあ英語だったらごく普通の単語です
イモータルというね 死なないというね
不死の概念 PEOPLECREATE
CREATE THE CONCEPT OF イモータル
なんでこの不死という概念を作るのかというと
死という事実を受け入れられないんです
能力ないんです 細胞に
細胞は生きていきたいだけだから
死ぬこともあり得ると
そんなこと認めたら 初めから話がずれますよ
だから認めません だから細胞レベルで死を認められません
だから生命が巨大な40兆の細胞組織になって
イモータル不死という概念が作ったんです
宗教はもう押し売っているのはこのイモータルなんです
そこで我々は生きられるんだから
ご飯に執着するは 金に執着するは
家族に執着するは 自分の考えに執着するは
そんなことではもう大した助けにならないと知っているのに
金があれば生きていられる
そうじゃないと知っていますよ
ちゃんとご飯だけ食べれば生きていられる
それはそうじゃないとみんな知ってますよ
なのに執着している そこで不死という概念を与えたら
どれぐらい執着すると思う？なんじこれこれやったら永遠の命になりますよと言ってくれたら
恐ろしくその意見に執着するんです
ご飯に執着している人間だからね
金に家族に財産に執着している人間だから
これ役に立たんやとわかっているのに執着していますよ
それで汝は永遠な命をいただきましょうと
うちの神様を信仰すればと言ったら
怖いほどその考えに執着する
はい 次のポイントに行きましょう
私は何を考えているのでしょうか
と  また別なポイントに行きます
今 宗教と宗教はそれで完了です
随分簡単で 全ての宗教
全ての哲学  私に戻りましょう
私は何考えてるんですかと
自分がどのような意見
概念を持って生きてるのかと自分でもわからないんです
本当のところ 私はどんな意見ですかね
どうかに 生まれて判断能力がついてから
考え意見などは変わりつつです
だから生まれたら脳幹だけなんで
だから生きてるだけなんですよ
大脳はあんまり仕事しない
大脳にはこのデータを受け入れるシステムができてますけど
考える能力はまだできてないんです
そこでなんとか考える能力が現れてから
考えが変わるわ 変わるわ
変わるわ ものすごく変わっていくんです
当たり前でしょうに 我々は小さい時からいろんな考えがあって
新しい新しい考えに変わっていくんです
一日中でも様々な意見が現れて消えていくんです
朝の思考と昼の思考違うしね
昼の考えと午後の考えが違う
午後の考えで夜になってくる
また別な考え そうやって次から次へと人間の考えが変わる
変わり変わり変わり流れていくんですね
だからあの質問に答えられないでしょ
あんた何考えてるもんですかと
人間バカだから答えちゃうんですよ
あれ 答えられない無きの質問なんです
あなたは何を考えているでしょうかと
答えられないんです それには
だからそれはかなり具体化しないと
はいはい 何についてですか？と
まあ何について？豆腐についてですよと言ったら意見があるんです
豆腐については豆腐の種類がたくさんあるんだからね
豆腐の中でもあなたどんな豆腐について意見聞いてるんですかとハッキリ聞いてください
厚厚揚げなんとかってあるしね
いろいろありますからね
あの干した豆腐もありますね
高野豆腐なんとか言ってね
だからどんな豆腐に対してでしょうか
そうやってどんどん具体的に持っていかないと意見は述べないはずなんです
考えは なぜならば 普通に売ってる絹とか何とかという豆腐に対する考えと
厚揚げに対する考え違うんだからね
それと高野豆腐に対する考え
また違うんです だからあんたどんな考えは何ですか？と聞いたら
これから答えないでください
答えたらバカになっちゃうんです
ハメられます  はっきりと出てこないと
脳はそういう組織なんです
時に私にも聞くんで あんた今の日本の状況をどう思っていますかと
何も思ってないんだから思考ないんです
具体的に 例えば総理大臣
名前何だったっけ ん？安倍総理大臣についてどう考えますかと聞いた方がいいでしょう
そうすると 安倍総理 私から見れば小さい時から生まれて大きくなっちゃって
今仕事をして それから年取って死んでいる
すべてのまとめた人間だから
それも答えられなくなっちゃいますから
もっと具体的に持ってこないとね
安倍総理大臣がやっているこれこれについてとかね
そうすると意見は述べますね
例えば 安倍総理さんの北朝鮮の原子爆弾の実験についての発表は
あんたどう思いますかと
それだったら言えるでしょうね
もっと厳しく言った方がいい
あるいはあんなのは発表したって意味がないとか
何か言えるんです 真偽を問う暇なんかはありません
私たちの脳にはこの真偽を問う暇がないんです
だって 次から次 次から次
意見が変わって変わって変わっていくんです
考えが変わって変わっていくんです
止まりません 固定した思考はありません
固定したものは絶対どこにも存在しないんだから
なんで思考だけ固定するんですかね
ありえないでしょ というわけで
私は何を考えているのでしょうか？なんです
いくら意見が変わっても
人は今持っている意見に固執します
これだけでしょ 変わらないのは
これが危険です 秒単位で意見が変わるんだけど
朝はトーストが美味しいなと思ったバカが
昼になってきたらやっぱりラーメンですねと言うんですよ
だから訴えなくちゃ あんた嘘言ってる
朝言ったことは嘘 今言ってるどちらは嘘？嘘でしょと
その人は嘘をついてるんじゃないんです
その時間によって意見が変わっただけなんです
朝という時間で やっぱりトーストの方が美味しいやと
食べるものだったらトーストに決まってるんだよと偉そうなことを言っちゃったんですね
これ 12時になってきたらやっぱりうどんでしようと言うんですね
だから朝言ったことと今言ったことは矛盾で
どちらが真偽ですかと聞く
バカバカらしいでしょ
その瞬間の意見だけなんです
でも 我々の病気は何なのかというと
その意見に固執するんです
昼ご飯になってうどん食べたがってる人に
うどんではなくて別な何かもう食べましょうやと言っちゃうと
本人が嫌がっちゃうんですね
やっぱりサンドイッチの方がいいんじゃない？食べやすいし
言ったら いやサンドイッチは気持ち悪いと
朝食べたのにね もう意見が変わってるんです
そういうことで よく皆さん覚えてください
私たちは 1 秒  1 分間で 1 億回も意見変えますけど
あの瞬間瞬間の意見に固執するんです
それが大きな病気です
固執できんでしょ そのすぐ変えますからね
真偽判断は無駄です すべての見解は存在欲と存在欲を刺激するものです
正しくても間違っても構わないんです
存在欲を刺激するならば
だってなんで映画見るんですか？あんな嘘に決まってるでしょ
飛行機でちょびっと一つの映画見たんだけど
あの ちょっと犬の話で
まあちょっとストレスかかってた犬ですごい凶暴になっちゃって
でもある男の子には犬がなつくんですね
でもあまりも怖いんだから近寄れない
夜 犬が吠えるも吠えるきりがなく
それで子供が降りてきて
犬のところに行ったら
犬は吠えることをやめちゃうんですね
で 帰ろうするとまた吠える
でも犬のそばに行くのも怖い
凶暴だから それでこの子はもう腹が立って
家の中の連中に怒られるし
寝られないんだから はい
分かった 仕方がないだろうと言って
そのまま外で寝るんですね
いくらなんでも外で寝るということはね
子供にとってはすごい体に悪い
健康に悪いものなんですけど
一応そのカットを取る
それで暗いですね 明かりは
そこで犬もできるだけ近寄ってきて
子供がいるところで寝て寝ているんですね
子供をなめようとするんだけど
子供になめられるところでもなかったんですね
だからそこで我々に言ってるストーリーは
子供 犬がこの子供のことをすごく好きで
一緒にいたい しかし子供は犬が怖いんだから
ちょっと近寄れない そこでお互い意見違いがあるということで
はい それはいいんです
そこで次のカット もうかなり明るい朝
お母さんがあんた起きたの？目が覚めたの
そちらで寝たのかと話しかけてくるんですね
これって現実世界ではありえない話でしょ
こんなすやすやと外で寝られる
そのまま芝の上で寝られないはずなんです
だから  2回分けて監督が映画を撮っただけでしょう
同じ場所で もう暗くなるまで待っていて
訓練させた犬をね 入れて吠えるようにしてあげて
それから子供は寝る はい
カット終わり それで じゃあ次の日
朝 次の日か もっと朝の場面は先に撮ったかもしれませんしね
朝の場面を先に撮って
午後になってから夜寝る場面を撮ったかもしれませんし
それはわかりません それ
繋げたものでしょ だからあんなインチキ
それ見ながらそれを思っていたんですね
なんで我々は見るんですかね
そこで私たちの脳が監督の思うままにストーリーを作るんです
ストーリーして感動して
いろいろうるさいと思ったのは私だけやと思いますよ
人類の中で 酷くてやることもないんだから
そういうことで 私が言いたいポイントは
正しくても間違っても構わないんです
映画を見て気分爽快になった方が存在に何かサポートになります
だってそれだけ だからエイリアンの映画も何でも見る
意見を持っている人はその
意見が正しいと決まっているのです
何かに対して意見が 2つ以上があるならば
それは真理ではないんです
意見 2つあると 例えばカボチャがある
カボチャについて私の意見と隣の人の意見が違う
2つだったらどうったことない
気にする必要もないんです
真理ではないんです 真理に対して多数の意見があるならば
あるはずはないんです
真理 事実だったら 多数の意見は現れないんです
本当は意見ないんです
真理に対して 真理は地球が丸いというようなものでなければなりません
地球が丸いっていうのは
あの意見もおかしいんです
なぜならば 我々はいろんな形があるものと比較しているだけなんです
あるいはかつて地球が平らだと思っていた
昔間違った考え 今引きずっているんです
どちらかよくわかりません
地球は丸いんだけど 地球丸いと言う必要はないんです
地球が丸いということは意見ではないんです
それは事実です だから数学的に地球の形なんですね
数学は人間が作ったものでしょ
数学を消してしまえば
丸いということも消えちゃう
だから地球は何ですかね
まあ仏教の答えは物質がつないでいるものだから
物質は因果法則によって繋ぐだけです
だから宇宙にある物質はすべて丸くはないんですね
小さいものは変な形を持ってますね
巨大なものだけ丸くなるんです
で見解が 2つ以上があるならば
気にする必要はありません
楽になってください 日本にしたってもたくさん宗教があります
いろんなこと言ってるでしょ
だったらみんな嘘です
簡単です しかし どちらが正しいと知りたくなるのも人間の気持ちです
だから私は調べた 日本の古い宗教
新興宗教を調べると みんなこの戦争崇拝はやってますね
だからそれ真理かというとそうじゃないんです
あれは宗教の商売道具なんですね
だから結局人間が戦争を大事にするんでね
日本人は 戦争のことを怖くて怖くてたまらんですね
だから怖いんだから いえ
ご先祖様に守られていると自分を騙す
それで元気に生きていられる
私をおじいさん守っている
私をひいおじいさん守っているとかね
その方が元気になるんですね
思って申し出た方が それだけの話でしょ
だからそこを分かったところで
教徒でやっている阿含宗とかは
派手にやっているのは戦争
何だらかんだらという専門用語がありますよね
戦争の怨念 なんとかなくすためのいろいろ供養なんかしなくちゃいけないと言って金取っているんです
だからただの違法的な経済活動ですよ
経済活動は合法ですからね
だって 何か人に役に立つものをあげて金をもらう
それは正当ですよ 何も役に立たないものをあげて金取るのはちょっと違法ですね
まあそれはどうでもいいんだけど
だからこの日本のどんな新興宗教も戦争崇拝やってるんだからといって
戦争崇拝が正しいわけじゃないんです
とにかく至って簡単 答えは意見
2つあるならば  2つも捨てなさいなんです
その時 データを調べるのではなく
自分好みで主観で自分の見解に一番近いもの
また自分の存在欲を刺激するものを誰でも選んでしまうんです
人間やっていること 例えば宗教は 3つある
皆様に宗教を 3つも提供する
そうすると その人がどちら選ぶ？宗教 3つあるとは？ 3つもダメでしょ
本当は 3つもさようならなんですが
やらないんです それで人間がこの今書いてデータ調べません
神様 唯一神様はシュワと言ったらシュワを信じた日本人もいましたし
イエホワ信じる人間もいるし
天照大神を信じるもいる
もうどうでもいいんですよ
だから自分の存在欲を刺激するものを選ぶだけです
正しいものを選んでいるわけじゃないんです
あるいは自分今持っている意見に近いもの
私も神様がいると思っていたんだからね
あなた言っていることははっきりしますから
イエホワですかね ではこれからイエホワ信じますと
イエホワ信じる人はやっぱり初めからもう似た迷信があったんですよ
だからキリスト教の方々は
このミャンマー スリランカですごい苦労するんです
だから絶対的神がいるという
あの基本的な文化でないんです
いろんな役柄を担う神々がいると信じているんです
すべてまとめるボスがいませんと
だから なかなかキリスト教の方々にとってはすごく難しいんです
そこで狙うのは スリランカの場合は
この仏教的に生きられない人間がいるんですよ
領主さんたちとかはね
どうせ初めから殺生はダメだって言ってるんだから
その人々はなんか自分たちのことをね
無視されている 差別されているという気持ちがあるんですね
そこで神様を信じることにするんですね
それだけなんです だから
この 自分のもともとあった気持ちに近いものを選ぶ
えーと 時間的にどうですかね
30 まだ半分も進んでないんですけど
テーマがすごく大きいんです
まあとにかくこれから飛ばします
これから仏教的なところ
今まで普通データ説明しました
これから仏教のところ
真偽ではなく 主観を正すと
この真偽はもう話にならんです
問題は主観のところにあるんです
そこを直せばいいんです
見解を捨てる 乗り越えることが仏道です
見解を持たないことが仏道です
複数の宗教哲学の背景
仏教は互い違い 複数の宗教がある背景で現れたんです
人間に推測できる宗教哲学は 62種類がある
あり得る ことを 長部経典の第一の経典に記してあります
だから長部経典を始めると始めた時も
世に現れるすべての宗教はこんなもんやとというところから始まっているんです
あれ 仏教のアプローチはものすごく違うものなんです
宗教哲学は 62種類が成り立つんだと
過去と未来に対する思考
存在 魂に対する思考 唯物論
虚無主義 懐疑主義などなどです
そのリスト 62のリストの中に
そういうものはすべて入っているんです
そこで現代人が哲学を作っても
あの中に一つに入るんです
ブッダのカテゴライズ神だからね
なかなかなもんなんです
そこで議論することは習慣でした
だって 62種類もありましたからね
誰でもお互い違う意見だから議論するんです
議論の技術を学んでいる人々は勝ちますが
自分の意見が正しいと立証することはできません
そこで宗教 2つの人々が集まって議論する
インドの習慣だから喧嘩じゃないんです
宗教議論はとてもかっこいいと思っているんです
いまだにそう思っているんです
インド文化はこの多宗教とは議論する
さばくことはしません
イスラム教はちょっと問題を起こしちゃいますけど
まあだからそちらはそういう態度がないんだから
ヒンドゥーの連中もその反応でイスラム教を潰そうとか思ったりするんですね
それはヒンドゥー教にとっては良くないことなんですね
ヒンドゥー教は多種 他の宗教を潰す宗教じゃないんです
で 議論するんですね イスラム教は議論禁止だから
これこそ真理です おかしくて嘘です
終わり 議論はできない
それでインドではこのディベートの技術を別で学ぶんです
これ別な学問なんです
議論すること かなり難しいんですよ
そこでこの議論の技に就いている人は
どこに行ったても勝っちゃう
勝ちが勝ってしまうでしょ
だから自分の意見が勝ったんだからといって
自分の意見が正しいということになってないんです
ただ 相手が口下手で負けただけなんです
相手の議論の方法が下手で負けただけなんです
だからインド人勘違いしていたんですね
議論に勝った人は正しい
それお釈迦様はこれ間違いだと
議論に勝ったからといって
相手の意見が正しいわけじゃないんです
だから私はインド文化の人間だから
議論のうちをいろいろ技知ってますよ
例えば冗談でディベートやりましょう
私があえて北朝鮮の立場が正しいという意見を持ちます
皆様方 みんな 1箇所になって
いえ 北朝鮮のやり方はとんでもない間違っていると
私とディベートしてみましょうか
私は勝ちます 問題ないんです
理由は techniques ofディベートというものを私は学んでいるんだからなんです
だからと言って私が言っている意見が正しいわけじゃないでしょう
時々私はこの議論のからくりをする
子供たちにはね すごい変なことを言ってね
これは違うでしょうと
いえ 私が言っている 正しいよと一応議論してみせますよ
で じゃあ間違っているならば
あんたつぶってみてくださいと
できないんですね だから子供はすごく怒って腹が立って違うのにとか
それで終わっちゃうんです
私はもう意図的にやるんです
もう私が出す意見が間違っていることは当たり前なんですけど
議論の技術を知らないんだから
子供にやっぱり私と対論することはできないんですね
それは私にとってはただの遊びでやっちゃいますから
だから議論で勝ったからといってね
意見が正しいわけじゃないんです
釈尊は議論の目的で仏教を学ぶことも
弟子たちは議論することも禁止したんです
だから仏教では議論することは禁止です
しかし 対話を認めたんです
議論ではなくて 話し合いましょうと
対話と議論の違うところは
議論は自分のスタンスを立証しなくちゃいけないんです
対話は私はこの意見ですけど
で 相手がああ なるほど
で なんでそういうふうな意見を作ったんですかと
どんな理由でしょうかと学ぶ
そこで向こうはあなたはどんな意見ですかと
あ 私はこういう意見ですよと
で なんであなたはこのような意見？私の意見とすごく違いますけどね
でもなんでその意見があるのかと聞いてみて
そこでデータがテーブルの上に来るでしょ
そこで比較して組み合わせて何か決めるんですね
決めなくてもいいんです
で 二人でも何か間違いない意見になりましょうやと思ったら
何か合わせて何かすればいいし
まあいいや もうさようなら
いい話でしたと別れることもできます
それは対話 ダイアローグ
ディベートではないんです
ディベートの場合は自分が勝たなくちゃあかんです
インド人がやったのはディベートなんです
ダイアローグではないんです
似ているんだから お釈迦様は
ディベート禁止 ダイアログ OK ということにしたんです
何かの意見にしがみつくのではなく
意見に固執する心の問題を直すんです
仏教的な立場は なんで我々は意見に固執するんですかと
意見が 1 秒で 100回ぐらいも変わるんだから
なのに固執する それ直すんです
はい そこでインドではこのディベート世界
ディベート ディベート
議論の世界の場合は よくやったフレーズがあるんです
私が正しい でないとディベート成り立ちません
ダイアローグは私が正しいと言った時点でダイアローグは終了です
すごい違うんですよ ダイアローグとディベートは
対話は私が正しいって言ったら
そこで対話が終わり さようなら
ディベートの場合は 俺は正しいよと始めなくちゃあかんです
そこでインドでは議論した人々はイダメワサッチャンモーガマンニャンというフレーズを使ったんです
イダメワサッチャンモーガマンニャン
意味書きます 私が述べている意見のみ正しいのです
他の意見のすべては間違っている
これだけ正しい 他すべて空という
意味なんですね ユースレス
イドメイワサッチャンモーガマニャン
だからお釈迦様のところにいろんな人が来て
そのフレーズで質問するんです
あの お釈迦様は答えない質問 10種類あるんですね
皆様に 11番目も教えましたからね
あんた何考えてるの？あれも答えられないんですよ
答えられない質問 世の中いっぱいあるんです
だからバカ答えて変なひどい目に遭いますけどね
一つは魂と体 肉体が同一ものですかと
お釈迦様に聞くんです
お釈迦様 魂と肉体が同一なものですか？これが真理で
他の意見すべて間違ってますかと
で 答えませんよ そんなのは
ある人に いえ 私はそういうふうに思いませんよと
いうふうに答えたところもあります
このようなスタンスであるならば
その人は真で事実を守ることすらできないんです
ちょっと守ることわからないかもね
説明します 私は事実を知らないかもしれません
意見があるんだけど もしかするとどうかなと
そういう私が いえ 私の意見正しいと言ってしまえば
その人にこれからも本当の事実を発見することはできなくなるんです
だから意見に固執するとは真理を蹴っ飛ばすことなんです
だから固執禁止なんです
あんた知ってることは別に間違ってるかもよ
別にいいんじゃないですか
だって 1 分間で変わりますからね
意見は 意見が間違ってもどうってことないんです
しかし 我々は絶対使ってはいけない言葉は
我こそ正しい 他の意見すべて間違っているなんです
だからお釈迦様にあるバラモンに言うんです
バラモンじゃなくて 別な宗教家なんです
あんたはね こんなこと言っちゃうと
バラモンです ワーシと言ったから
真理を守ることさえできませんよと
だからイドメイワサッチャンモーガマニャンと言うなよと
一人います ちょっと時間なくなりますけど
もう若者 東大の息子かな
ちょっと今思い出せません
で バラモンたちが 有名な有名なバラモンたちが
お釈迦様と大きな対話催し物やったんですね
で かなり派手にお釈迦様がいるところに
すごい長老のとても有名なバラモンたちが来て
超エリートたちで対話すると
それでお釈迦様が年上の方々と普通の話をしているんですよ
そちらでかなり若者がいたんですね
この若者が参加するのは
こいつは天才なんです
だからバラモン人たちが年取るまで学んだものは
こいつは若い時全部学んで終わってるんです
だからものすごく可愛がって
こんな若くてすべての学問を終わってるんだからということで
一人前でこのグループに参加したんです
どうせ若者ってのは落ち着かないでしょ
大事な対話しようとあったのに
お釈迦様って今頃元気？とかね
体の体調でもどうですかね？とかね
今頃ね 天気もね 暑くてね
大変ですねとかね そんな話してるんです
体調はどうですかとかね
牛はちゃんと元気でいるのかどうかね
この子はもうイライラしているんです
そこで時間かけるお釈迦様は一人一人で対話するんです
全部世間話 世間話ではないんだけど
普通常識的な対話なんです
これでこの人が口を挟んだんです
口を挟んだお釈迦様がものすごい厳しい言葉で
私は今 年上の長老たちと対話しているんだと
この長老たちの対話にね
口を挟む あんた何者かと
黙っていなさいと 行儀悪いんだと怒鳴ったんです
これはインドの行儀悪いんです
仏教も厳しいんだけどね
大事な二人が話をすると割り込んだらあかんです
そこでこの人落ち込んじゃったんです
そうすると長老たちがバラモンたちが
お釈迦様はこの子は若いんだけど
一人前ですよと お釈迦様と対話する資格は全部持ってるんだよと
そしたらお釈迦様はあんまり何も言わない
言わない それでも ただ
この若者が自分の立場を取り戻されたんだから
では黙って待ちます お釈迦様は私の方を見たところで質問しますと
お釈迦様が世間話終わってから若者の方を見たんですね
見たら この人はお元気ですか？ではない
いきなり質問したんです
我々お釈迦様がね このサンヴェーダが唱えることこそ
梵天に生まれ変われる唯一の道である
他の方法すべて間違っていると思っています
我こそ正しい すべて間違っています
ただ お釈迦様があのね
あなたの先生たちが 我々はまず本人に
あなたはこれこそ梵我一如の唯一な道である
体験している 私は体験してないんだけど
先生たちはそうおっしゃっているんだよと
では その先生たちはそれ体験して
私がこれ知っていると説かれている
いえいえ 先生たちもそう言ってない
先生の先生たち はい はあ
じゃあ 3代目の方々はこれ確かめている？いい
確かめてない で  7代まで行って確かめてない
それでお釈迦様がアッタカわーわーアッタカわーまくわーでウェッサンギータわーバグというこの 8人の仙人たちがいるんですよ
ヴェーダ聖典を作った人々
あの仙人たちがヴェーダ聖典を作った
このマントラを作った
作成した人々が 我はこれを知っている
体験している 証明立証していると言っているんですかと
言ったら それお釈迦様も勉強しているんだからね
この若者に嘘を言えないんです
あの仙人たちが神を讃嘆する文書を作っただけで
これ正しいと言ってないんです
だから言ってないんだと
あのね それだったらヴェーダ聖典を作った人にもものは見えない
次の人にもものは見えない
次のあなた方はなんか御倉の流れやと
前の人にも見えない その末掴まってる次の人にも見えない
その末使ってる次に誰にも見えないやと言ったら
もう大ショックで だからそんなこと言うなよと
私のこと正しいと言ったら
あなたは真理を守ることすらできないんだと
言ったら若者負けちゃって
お釈迦様に真理を守る方法を教えてくださいと素直に聞いたんですね
しかし 事実を守る 大事にするというアプローチが必要です
事実知らなくちゃではないんです
知らなくてもいいんです
事実を大事にしなくちゃいけない
それだけ 自分の意見が正しいと思ってしまう仕組みが問題です
だって自分が正しいという仕組みがあるでしょ？これが問題です
この気持ちは真理を発見すること
ん？これは字が間違ってます
こうなんで この個人の個じゃないんです
真理を発見することの障害になります
だから皆様も今日から私が正しいという気持ちを捨ててください
そうすると 真っ直な人間になります
間違っても大丈夫です
安全です この問題について
中部経典のマジュニカスッタナンバーナインティーファイブチャンキースッタというところで詳しく書いてあります
では 一旦休憩して 経典に入りまして
入りましょう では  では
5 分ぐらい休憩いたします
では 始めます はい もうもう頭はまだ意見
次から次へと変わりますから
今新しい頭にしてください
これ順番で流れで 私は意見変わるということを知った上で
どんどんどんどん話を持っていくんです
これからこのチャンキー経典の中身
ほんの一部だけ紹介していきます
見解の元になる 5つの気持ち
私たちは何か理解する
何かの意見を持つ 見解を持つ
なんで我々の脳が いくつかの意見の中から 1つ選ぶんですかと
脳にとってそんなに偉そうなことできるわけないでしょ
はい この意見 この意見が正しい
例えば選挙がある いくつかの政党が出ている
皆様 投票にしたら誰かに投票するでしょ
その判断正しい？わからないでしょ
わからないんだけど この党もあの党もこの党もありまして
じゃあこちらにしまって決めて決めるでしょう
これって何ですかね どうやって決めたんですかね
いつでも私たちはそういうことをやっているんです
いつでも 選挙でなくても
レストランに行ったらメニューもらっちゃうでしょ
いろんな食べ物あるでしょう
そこで 1つ決める なんでそんなこと食べ物に決めたんですかね
5つあります これはこの一
サッダ信仰 サッダっていうのは
この場合の信仰は この宗教で言っている信仰なんですね
信仰するためには別に証拠なくてもいいんです
で 例えば神様が絶対的神様がいる
天地創造をしたんだと信仰する
それから  それに適したアイデアがいくらでも頭に入ります
例えば私は仏教の立場でからかっちゃって言うんですけど
カトリック教の場合はいつでも私たち仏像に拝むでしょ
その代わりに彼らがこの十字架にイエス様を釘打たれている
あれを持っていって大事に拝んでるんですね
私はこの連中にこの残酷なものでなければ信仰生まれませんよとかね
冗談言うんだけどね グロテスクで
残酷で これって神の姿ですかとかね
言いたいんだけど 仏像を見たらすごくやさしい気持ちで
何の問題もない 問題そこで解決したんだという形で仏像を造ってるでしょうに
これと正反対なんですね
極端に苦しんでる状態で
いわゆる大失敗状態です
しかし その方々にとってそれが信仰対象なんですね
なぜならば 人間が犯した罪の代わりに
神様が自分の命で弁償している姿なんですね
だからありがたくてたまらんでしょ
あの姿が 十字架にイエス様が釘を打たれた姿がもうありがたくてたまらん
私たちの罪のために なんで神様がこんな苦労してくれたと
なんてすごいことだと
そこでその信仰あるとそう思います
私はその信仰ないでしょ
だから私は変なことをいっぱい言うんです
もう怒ることは覚悟の上で
神様にも生贄必要みたいなとかね
だって神が全知全能だったら
イエス殺す必要ないでしょ
じゃあわかった 君らの罪を許してあげるぞと
一発で許しちゃえばいいのに
やっぱり生贄が必要 なんだこりゃと
でも その私の反論は キリスト教を信仰する方々に頭に入ってこないんです
なぜならば 自分の信仰によってアイデアが現れるんだから
だから別に私が言ってる
もうなんて言いますか
からかって人をバカにする意見は正しいと思ってないよ
ただもうからかってるだけ
どうでもいいんで 私にとっては
1 サッダ信仰にルチ好み
この細胞組織になんか好みが現れちゃうんですね
じゃあ好みに合わせてこれが正しい
これが間違っていると決めるんです
サンアヌッソウ これは言い伝え
伝統 これはみんなにありますよ
だから皆様は日本人だと言ってるでしょ
日本人だと皆様は自分のアイデンティティを出す場合は
昔からの日本の国の伝統を受け継いでいるんだって意味なんです
自分の好き嫌い 考え それによって
調整しているんだって意味なんです
日本文化に合わせて調整しているんだと
だから だいたい皆様 私は日本人だと言っているたびに
皆様方は日本文化を気にしているんです
ということは自分の意見でしょ
意見が伝統によって作ったんです
例えばご飯を食べると
俺は日本人だからナイフとフォーク持ってきてこいと言わないでしょ
そうすると変ですね だから俺は日本人だからと言った途端
ご飯を食べているんだから
箸を出さなくちゃいかんでしょ
それでこの文章が成り立ちますね
私は日本人ですが ナイフとフォークでご飯を食べます
その場合はが入れるんですね
誰も私は日本人だからナイフと
持ってこいとは言わないんですね
それで私は日本人だと言っている場合はわかりますかね
伝統と文化なんですね
ということは 私の生き方はその伝統と文化によって変えているんだという意味なんです
そういうわけで  3番目の人間の意見が変わる
3番目の理由はアヌッサバです
4番目はアーカルパ・パリビタック
これ 理屈思考と私は訳したんだけど
あんまり訳できないんですね
で アーカルパもフォーマルロジックという風にも言えるし
まあいろいろ考えて こうだからこうで
こうだからこうで こうだからこうでしょというふうな考えなんですね
例えば警察官が犯罪犯人を探す場合は
もうこれでやっちゃうんですね
この似ている人が CCTV カメラに映っていました
で その人にはアリバイはなかった
で 他の証言によると ここら辺うろうろしたっていうこともある
だからこの人は疑わしい
取り調べも行って あんたやったでしょとか
いろいろそれから聞いたりする
その場合は 4番目ですね
アーカルパ・パリビタック 5
ディッティニッジャーナカンティ
自分の意見 見解に合う納得ということで
何か人が何か言っていると
なんかすぐ納得しちゃう場合あるでしょ
あるいは全然納得できない場合もあるでしょ
私の話みたいに いくら言っても全然納得してくれない
それは当然だと思いますよ
だけど これ革命的な認識に革命的なことばっかり言ってるんだからね
で ああ あの人の話はよく納得できますと言ったら
あなたはもともとそれのような
なんてフォーマットを持っていたんだようなんです
だからそのフォーマットを持ってるんですよ
それにうまくデータが入っただけなんです
このような理由でで達する見解は正しいか否かは五分五分です
お釈迦様が言うんです
この信仰 好み 言い伝え
伝統 理屈 あるいは納得ことで
あなたは何か意見を持っても
これって五分五分だと
いわゆる真偽の場合は五分五分だと
信仰に問題はないが 信仰する見解は嘘かもしれませんね
偽物かもしれません あの何か信仰するという精神状態は別に
これはいいんです 別に
問題ではありません だから何を信仰するかっていうことで結果が出るんです
そこで何かを信仰する
でもそれは本当に嘘です
例えば大川隆法がブッダの生まれ変わりだと信仰する
それが問題です 誰かを信仰することは問題じゃないんです
なぜならば それは嘘だから
だから信仰であなた真偽を発見しよう
真理を発見しようと思っちゃうと
あんた五分五分だよと
信仰したものが嘘かもしれませんね
あるいは信仰する対象が正しいんです
例えばブッダを信仰する
ブッダが悟っているんだから対象は正しいんですが
信仰が曖昧だったらどうする？そうするとブッダの教えを学ぶことができなくなっちゃうんですね
曖昧でいい加減で だから信仰も揺らぐんだからね
だからあまり信仰に頼るなよということです
他のものにも同じ理論でお釈迦様は言っているんです
例えば理屈 データそろって理屈
理屈自体が間違っていたら
結論間違っているでしょ
あるいは理屈は論理方法は正しいんだけど
データが間違っていると
だからいつでも五分五分
いつでも五分五分なんです
だから警察は犯人やつ捕まった人がまた無罪だと分かって解放される時
いくらでもあるでしょうに
誤解で逮捕されることもあるでしょうに
信仰は曖昧ですが 見解は正しいかもしれません
真理を守る人はこのようなことをします
これは私の信仰です 私の言い伝えの意見です
などなどを強調しなくてはいけないんです
だから我々はこうしなくちゃあかん
これは私の信仰はこういう信仰ですと
これ正しいと言わないんです
私のこれは私の信仰ですと
これは私の好みですと
例えばヒンドゥー教の人がガネーシャという神様を信仰しているかもしれません
だから ヒンドゥー教のその人がいい
ガネーシャこそが神である
ガネーシャというのは頭象の神なんです
ガネーシャこそが神だという必要はないんです
私はガネーシャ神様のこと好きや
言った方がいいやと 他の神もいるんだけど
シヴァもいるんだけど
カーリーもいるんだけど
ラーマもいるんだけど
いろんな猿もいるんだけど
それいろんな神々の中で
なんとなくもうお腹がでっかいんだから
ガネーシャの方が好きやと
それだったらいいんです
お釈迦様は認めます なぜならば
その人は真理も真理を守っている
もしかすると本物の神は別なものかもしれません
でも好きだからやっているんだから
本人知ってるんだから
そこで私たちも何か人に意見を言う場合は
私は勉強したところから言えば
こんな意見です 私の上司が言ったことから言えば
こんな意見です 私の友達に聞いてみたら
こんな意見でという このちゃんとこのスタンスを出してくださいと
絶対言ってはいけない言葉は
私が正しい これが正しい意見
それだけ絶対言ってはいけないんです
これもいいんです まあ個人好みで言えば
これやと 例えば個人好みで言えば
日本は戦争するべきですと
それでいいんです 個人好みだから
それにケチをつける必要はないんです
私は個人の好みで言うならば
日本は戦争に行った方がいいやと
しかし こう言ってはならない
日本は戦争しなきゃ大国にならない
潰れるかも だから必ず戦争するべきです
他の道はありませんと言ったらアウト
その人はバカです その人は本当の道を見つからないんです
ですから 個人の意見だったら
日本国が戦争に行った方がいいやと言いというのは構いませんよ
私はこのわかりやすい例を出しただけです
だって大体皆様は戦争するべきやと思ってないんだからね
日本人ほとんど誰も戦争するべきだと思ってない
なのに誰かさんが一人がね
いえいえ 戦争するべきやと思っていても構いませんよ
しかし その人に義務があります
これは私個人の意見ですという一言葉を言う義務があるんです
私の意見こそが正しい
と言わないのです これがブッダのアドバイスです
次 お釈迦様が真理を発見する道を教えるんです
地道な努力になります
それは簡単じゃないんです
まずバイアスの問題 意見
見解 知識は存在欲を支えるものなので
初めからのバイアスがかかっています
どんな生命も世の中のことを学ぼうと思ったっても無駄なこと
あれは存在欲を支えるためなんです
初めからもバイアスで始めているんです
生き延びるためになんです
学びましょう この色眼鏡でなければ知ることはできません
我々の生まれつき障害でしょ
知識障害です 生まれつき
一部の人間だけじゃないですよ
認知障害は 生命は生まれつき認知障害です
存在欲 インスタントオブサバイバル
そのがそれがあって その色眼鏡があって
物事を知っているんです
意見が正しいか否かではなく
自分に正しく認識できるのか否かは大事なポイントです
ですから ちょっと難しい文章になりました
意見が正しいかないかっていうことよりも
我々は気をつけるのは
私に正しく認識できるんですかねと
このバイアスの問題 だからこれから私たちは仏教徒として
何でも知ってやるそうではなくて
何でも知ってやるぞと思ったんだけど
この方法でいいでしょうかと
このバイアスがあるんだからね
これどうしようと そこら辺困った方がいいんですね
存在欲ととは貪瞋痴の感情です
これでもさらにわかりやすくします
私はちょっとかっこつけちゃって
インスタントオブサバイバルとかね
存在欲とかね すごい難しいかないかわかりませんだけど
もう現代っぽい言葉を使ったんだけど
仏教では貪瞋痴やと 物事を貪瞋痴で知るんだと
だから知識のために貪瞋痴が必要です
科学研究するために貪瞋痴が必要です
変でしょ だから我々はいつでも貪瞋痴というすごいバイアス
すごい分厚い色眼鏡を持っているんです
この分厚い色眼鏡で見るものは一つもただの見解であって
主観であって 真理に関係ないんです
ですから バイアスなくすんです
難しいんですよ 貪瞋痴をなくして
皆様 なんで大学に入ったのかって？貪瞋痴があったからでしょ？なんで仕事をしているんですか？で
これ貪瞋痴があるからでしょ？なんで新聞読んでるんですか？貪瞋痴があるからでしょ
貪瞋痴のためにやっているんです
だから新聞を読んでも
自分の貪瞋痴の偏見でデータを覚えたり忘れたりしているんです
5つの項目言いましたからね
サッダールチアヌッソーカーパリルタッカタというね
皆さん 私のようには暗記してください
サッダールチアヌッソーカーパリルタッカディティリャーナカンディ
その 5つでバイアスがかかっているんです
もっとわかりやすく言えば
皆様に覚えやすいのは貪瞋痴
すべて貪瞋痴という色眼鏡で見ているんです
だから貪瞋痴なくしたければ
これ新たな外科のお世話にならないと
外科手術は必要です だから医者を選ばなくちゃいかんですね
この場合は知識ですから
師匠を選ばなくちゃいかんのです
師匠の心は貪瞋痴で汚れているか否か
心が汚れているにも関わらず
真理を知っていると錯覚して教えているか
だからお釈迦様が言うのは
師匠を選んでくださいと
師匠勝手に選ぶんじゃない
テストしてくださいと
師匠を これも革命的でしょ
普通だったら 伝統だったら
貪瞋痴の世界だったら
師匠が弟子をテストするんですね
弟子として受けるかないかと
仏教は逆を言うんです
生徒が師匠をテストするんです
この人を選ぶか選ばないかと
だから選ぶ場合は お釈迦様は貪瞋痴でチェックしてくださいと
例えばある有名な先生がいる
その先生 素晴らしいことを喋っている
口が達者 死んだ人の言葉まで言ってくれる
その人 生きている間は何も喋れません
嘘バレますからね だからそれに行くんじゃなくて
この人の心が欲で溺れ汚れているのかというと
欲そのもの 今私が間接的に言った人が欲
怒り 嫉妬そのものでしょ
だからこの人の心が欲
欲で汚れているのか あるいは自分でも欲があるのに欲がないと勘違いしているのか
調べなさいと この人言っていることを本当にわかっているんですかと
わかったつもりで言っているのかいと
私はエルカンターレであると言った途端
ああ なるほどではないんで
バカですよ あのね エルカンターレって何ですかね？とかね
どこから取った単語？なんで別荘の名前悪いとか
そうやってちょっと調べなくちゃあかんです
それで 次に この人が知っているつもりで喋っていて
そんなことを信仰したら人々は不幸になるんではないかと調べなくちゃいけない
そこで調べていくと こう発見する
あ この師匠の心が貪瞋痴で汚れていない
この師匠が真理発見している
発見したものを弟子たちに教えている
弟子たちもそれで幸福になっている
よく分かった 師匠は合格ですと弟子が師匠にテストして合格点をあげなくちゃあかんです
それはお釈迦様が自分のことを言っているんです
お釈迦様をテストしてくださいと
合格させるのは弟子なんです
ブッダが合格ですと 自分で真理を発見して
その通りに教えているかと調べるんです
だが簡単じゃないでしょう
だから皆様に あっても
仏教をやりたければ ブッダの経典はブッダがいないんだからね
経典を学んで 本当に心汚れたアホにこんなことを語れるのかと調べなくちゃいけないんです
ブッダが言ったことをやってみたら
ひどい目に遭うかないかと
そういうテストしなくちゃあかんです
皆様方 テストするんです
それでお釈迦様とは 今仏教だからね
お釈迦様おっしゃった教えだからね
そこで皆様のテストで合格したならば OK です
そこで師匠を信頼するんです
師匠がテストに合格したならば
その人を信頼するのです
あ この人は私は私の外科手術
この人にできるんだと
だからお釈迦様は信仰という能力を捨てなさいと言ってないんです
これはもう仕方がないんです
信仰する癖 我々持っているんだからね
だからいい加減信仰しないで
無批判で信仰しないで
相手をテストして信仰するんです
だから イエホワさんが自分が全知全能の神であると言っているならば
テストしてほしいんです
これは禁止されていますね
神をテストすること アッラーこそ神やと言っているならば
アッラーをテストしなくちゃあかんです
テストは禁止です だったら捨てなさいよと
そんなのはやるなよと
それと暇があったら水素爆弾でも作っちゃえと
役に立ちますよと 人を殺せますから
だからあの水素爆弾することはマシですよ
あの ああいう絶対的神をテストするなよということよりも
大した危険はないんだからね
作ったっても ただ 北朝鮮の一般人がね
経済状況がお金がないんだから飢えているだけの話ですからね
そこで私はあえて信仰という言葉を入れ替えたんだけど
お釈迦様が信仰という言葉を使っているんです
しかし 理性的な信仰 アーカーローティーサッダ―
理由があって信仰する
宗教は理由がないから信仰しなさいというんです
立証できんから信仰しなさいと
仏教は理由を探して 立証できるならば信仰しなさいと
ここで信仰が必要です
なぜならば 今私には貪瞋痴のバイアスがある
お釈迦様がもうバイアスないんですね
私の心を支持しなくちゃいかんですね
だからお釈迦様 助けてくださいと言わなくちゃあかんです
導いてください これは信仰といいます
理由なく盲目的な信仰は禁止です
仏教では情報を調べて確かめて納得してから心に起こる信頼感は正しい信仰です
正しい信仰というのは
心に起こる信頼感 あ この人なら信頼できる
そこで学びの始まり これパーリ語も入れます
まあただ読むだけで十分だと思います
サッダージャートウプサンカミティ
信仰が起きたらそちらに行く
例えばお釈迦様を信仰することになった
お釈迦様はテストに合格しました
そうすると弟子が 師匠のところに行って
私は弟子として認めなさいと言うんです
いつでも仏教の場合はそのやり方なんです
今も経典を読んでみてください
お釈迦様は汝弟子になりなさいと一度も言ってないんです
いつでも逆です 釈尊 今日から私は仏法僧を信仰します
弟子として認めてくださいと
だからこの権力は一般人に与えています
宗教と正反対です 仏教は
だから仏教は宗教と思ったら
そんなとんでもない話です
すべて宗教の正反対の特色なんです
私を弟子として認めてくださいと信仰する人が言わなくちゃいけないんです
仏教側からは あなたは仏法僧を信じなさいよとは言わない
ということで お釈迦様は単純な言葉でウパサンカミティというのは
この学校に入る 農学するブッダの学校にウパサンカンカミットはパイロパせて学校に入ってすぐ学ぶことはしません
近寄ってから付き合う
ブッダの道 ちょっと長い
よし あなたの言うこと全部学んでやるではなくて
もうちょっと付き合ってみてくださいと
当時ではできましたからね
お釈迦様の弟子になってから
別に学ぶこともなく 普通に一緒に生活してみる
お釈迦様と一緒に托鉢に行ったり
お釈迦様が説法するところでいろいろお世話したり
いろんなことをしたり
いろいろお坊さんたちとも話し合ってみて
仲良くしてみて その雰囲気
環境で学ぶんです まず
なぜならば もしかするとお釈迦様は世間に向かっていいことを言うんだけど
一人で森に入ったら別なことを言うかもしれませんね
だから個人的にも公でも個人的にも付き合ってみてくださいと
これはお釈迦様はあえて言っているんです
私の生き方を調べてください
公での生き方 個人としての生き方
だからブッダにプライバシーなんかないんです
いくらでも調べられます
ウパサンカンとソウタンオーダーで付き合って耳を傾け
だから付き合ってみると
なんとなく話も聞く羽目になるでしょ
サーリプッタ尊者もモクレン尊者アーナンダ尊者ともちょっと挨拶して一言を喋ってみる
どうですか？お元気ですか？とかね
この村でどれぐらい滞在するんでしょうか？とかね
また明日も会いたいんだけど
何時間よろしい そういう風に付き合ってみて
そうするとどんどん話を聞かなくちゃあかんでしょ
お釈迦さんに付き合っていると
お釈迦様はずっと説法ばっかりしているんだから
話を聴く気持ちが だから話を無理やり聞くことよりも
ここでブッダ様 お釈迦様をピンポイントするのは
話を聞きたくなった気持ちなんです
やっぱり聞きたいと 今日説法するんだから聞かなくちゃとかね
この心の中から その聞きたいという気持ちが生まれてほしい
だからお釈迦様 精密な脳科学者でしょ？精密な脳科学者なんです
無理やりに義理で義務で勉強したって勉強にならんです
私たちのやり方が間違っているんです
オーヒテソウトダンマンスナーティ
耳を傾けて それからこう教えを聞く
スッタダンマンダーリーティ
聞いた教えを覚えておく
これ必要です ICレコーダーでレコーディングしたって意味がないんです
このものにね 紙に書いてノート書いておいたっても
これ勉強じゃないんです
これ脳を変えなくちゃあかんでしょ
脳ってえらいわがままだからね
脳がもう持ってるデータで結論
最終結論付けちゃうんです
だって脳にはやつ脳でなければ機能しないでしょ
だからどうにもないんです
入ったデータで はい これというふうに決めちゃうんです
信頼できない装置ですよ
だからお釈迦様が提案するのは
この聞いた話をね 脳にデータとしてインプットしてくださいと
そうするといい加減な脳という組織にはいい加減な結論はできません
データがあるんだからね
データに合わせて結論を出すんです
そういうわけで ブッダの話を聞いて覚えるということが必要です
とにかく皆様の人格も変わった
良くなったと言ったならば
良くなった時は必ず 私がたくさん喋ってますけど
わずか 1 行でも覚えたものなんです
心で覚えたものが役に立ったんです
メモに書いたものじゃないんです
我々の人格を変えるのは
私の場合も同じなんです
で 経典膨大にあります
すぐ読めるし アクセスもできるし
でも役に立たん そこで頭に覚えているものあるんですね
それがかなり人格を変えてくれるんです
次にダターナンダンマーナンアッタンウポカーパリティ
覚えた教えの意味を観察する
これってどういう意味でしょうかとかね
皆様覚えてますね 日々是教実という経典でね
過去は過ぎ去ったもので
将来はまだ生まれていないもので
だから今の瞬間のことを観察して生きましょうと
過去に引っ張られなく
将来に期待することもなく
現在に生きようではないか
それを暗記しておくと
これってどんな意味でしょうかと考えるでしょう
それで発見するでしょう
過去では生きられない
将来には生きられない
生きているのは今だから
そういうふうに人格が変わります
覚えた教えの意味を観察する
調べる アッタンウパーリッカトダンマーニッジャーナンカマンティ
法真理の意義を観察すると納得する
あ 納得というバイアスのあれ
お釈迦様使っているんです
信仰も使っているんです
論理も使ってます あの人がものを判断する場合は 5つ
サッダー ルチ アーカーパリヴィターカ
と なんだかもう忘れちまった
ディッティニッジャーナカンティ
バッブルウッタとかね
その 5つですから その 5つをお釈迦様使ってるんです
正しく お釈迦様をテストすると
あ なるほど この人には貪瞋痴がなさそう
調べても調べても貪瞋痴がない
教えもすごい 結構みんな穏やかになっている
それでこれだから これだからこれ
これだからこれ だからいいんじゃないと
これはアーカラパリヴィターカなんですね
バッバループターなんですね
だからこの この主観作る時
持っている我々の基本フォーマットをお釈迦様はそのまま正しく使っているんです
そこで人はブッダの教えを調べる
学んで 調べて研究していく上で納得するんです
ああ なるほど これか これだと
納得したら ダタダンマニッジャーナカンティアサティチャンドージャハティ
真理に対して納得が生じたら意欲が現れる
この意欲というのは この脳の中で自動発生しなきゃできないんです
やる気 意欲っていうのは欲じゃないんです
じゃあ貪瞋痴のバイアス破った方がいい
破れますと やりますという気持ちが生まれなくちゃあかん
これは脳で発生しなきゃ効き目がないんです
チャンドージャートウッサハティ
意欲が起きたら精進する
それだと勉強しますと思ったらやるでしょ？ウッサヒトワトゥレーティ
精進しつつ比較してみる
この場合 比較といったっても
このまあいろいろ修行しながら
これだからこうで これだからこれとかね
この貪瞋痴のからくりをね
よく発見して まるっきり科学的なアプローチなんですね
例えば瞑想すると何とか気持ち悪くなってくると
気持ち悪くなっている
気持ち悪いとは怒りであって
なんで怒りが生まれたのか
なるほどなるほど こういうことがあったんだからとかね
で こういうことあったんだから
そういう比較なんですね
瞑想したいと座ったんだけど
なんかすごい眠気で なんだこれはとかね
そういう風に自分の状況を調べていかなくちゃいかんです
ただ瞑想しましただけではダメです
特に男性の方々は 私はこれから 3ヶ月間も毎日朝 8時から 9時まで
昼これからこれ これで私にこのレポートを持ってくるんですよ
私はこんなの意味がないんだけどって気持ちなんですけどね
精密に時間まで言うんです
夜は寝る前に 9時半から 10時半まで瞑想しますとかね
これじゃないんですけどね
だからこのやっただけでは意味がないんです
スケジュール組んでマンナリでやっただけでは意味がないんです
スケジュール組んでもスケジュール通りにできない場合もありますよ
例えば今日は朝 3時に起きて瞑想すると決めるのはいいんだけど
起きられない場合もありますからね
スケジュール通りにいかないんですよ
それはいいんです 仏教的に言えば
これで比較してくださいよと
なんでこうなったのか
どういう理由でそうなったのかと客観的にスタディするんです
それが修行なんです トレイとはパターで
それで比較してみてから
私は実践するという言葉を使ったんだけど
正しくないんです 比較してからさらに精進するなんです
それからもう一つ意味があります
本格的に瞑想に取り込む
最初は瞑想をやっているか
妄想しているか 寝ているか
もうくどい わからないんですよ
でもそういうことで どんどんどんどん比較して調べて調べていってると
本格的にじゃあやるぞということを
本番ができる時間が出てくるんです
はい っていうのは分析
分析っていうのと  うん
それは何と比べるのかな
比較する 自分のデータ
因果法則を発見するためにも比較しなくちゃいかんでしょう
それで私 単語はあまりよくわからないね
例えばこちら 火がついたとしましょう
え？なんで火がついたのかと
あ こちらこれがあったんだから
このコンセントがショートしていたんだ
だからそれなんですね
前と  比較すると条件いろいろね
そういう比較なんですね
だから比較といえば 私もよくこの単語は好き
好きわけじゃないんだけど
アナリシスもあるし カンパリションもあるしね
イヴァルエーションという意味もありますしね
まあとにかく なんで こうなっているものなんですよ
そこで本格的に実践やってみる
もういろいろ比較して全部わかったところで
実践すると 自分自身で最初の真理を発見するんです
世の中の意見じゃないんです
それと全く関係ない本当の真理を発見するんです
ん？最？私はもっと優れたということを書きたかったんだけど
漢字間違ってるかも これ間違ってる？直しましょうか
間違ってるとも言えませんけど
優秀 優の優です  最優ですね
読み方 最優の真理を発見すると
パンニャーチャナンアティヴィッジャパッサティ
智慧によって鋭く見られるようになる
初めも智慧という言葉出ましたもう
だから真偽は問う必要ありません
無駄です 我々の初めからもう生きるために物事を知っているだけで
そんなのを置いておいて智慧を開発しましょうということなんです
そこで智慧がもう現れているんです
エッターワタサッチャマヌブッジェティ
ここで真理を発見したというのです
最優の真理を発見したら
もう発見したということです
ナトゥエーワターワサッチャアヌパッティ
まだ真理に達していないんです
真理は発見したんだけど
自分自身が真理になってないんです
お釈迦様はもうステップ入れるんです
ヴィパッサナー瞑想進んでいる方々は
これ一番ややこしいところで
無常や無常やとわかりましたよと
偉そうなこと言う 自我がないとわかったよとかね
もうわかったことはわかったんだけど
もうステップあるんだよと私は言いたいんです
あんまりもうそこを納得してくれないんです
もう自我がないんだからね
わかりましたから とかね
わかっただけでも足らないんです
それ真理にならなくちゃあかんのです
ダンマナンアーセーワナバーワナバウリーカンマサッチャアヌパッティホーティ
発見した真理 実践する
育てる 繰り返すことで真理に達します
そこでただヴィパッサナー瞑想で
やっぱり生滅相滅尽 無常無常だとわかっても
それでは足らないんですね
そこはさらにさらに 繰り返し繰り返し
リピートしてリピートして修行していると
どんどん脳の中でしっかりしたプログラムが起きちゃって
変わっちゃうんですね
だから真理に達しなくちゃあかんのです
真理にならなくちゃあかんのです
わかることは脳が先にするんです
脳が主体でいてわかる
次に脳がそのものになるステップなんです
本当の悟りっていうのは
その最後のステップなんです
というわけで 仏教の道はただの知識遊びではないんです
テーマはそんな感じで
何が正しい 何が間違っているのかという感じで書いてあってます
あったんだけどね あれは私にとっては発表している文章はちょっとした知識遊びなんです
そんなもんじゃないんです
この道は新たな見解を取り入れることではありません
我々は知識遊びをして
この人言っていることもおかしい
あの言っていることもおかしい
この人は言っていることもちょっとだけまし
しかし この人の意見は素晴らしいというふうに
一つの意見を取り入れるんですよ
いろんな意見を捨てて捨てて
だからどんなゴミを捨ててどんなゴミを取り入れるのかという話じゃないんです
仏教の話は あなたは家に持っていくべきゴミは何なのかと
ゴミと言った時点で家に持っていくべきものじゃないでしょうに
見解はすべて仏教ではゴミというんです
はい 本能である存在欲を乗り越えることです
だから知識そのものを乗り越えちゃうんです
知識は存在欲のために
いわゆる貪瞋痴のために貪瞋痴を乗り越えるんです
輪廻転生を乗り越えることです
正しい見解は存在しないんです
あの八正道で正見ということがあるんだけど
本当はあれは正しい見解という意味じゃなくて
見解ないことなんです
その場合は 八正道の場合は正見の中身ちゃんと書いてありますからね
それに達したら正見ですけど
あれは単語で正見と呼ぶんです
正見という場合は 邪見という比較的な単語があるんです
仏教の正見というのは正見
邪見正見と関係ない なんとかもう正しいスタンスなんです
ですから 今日この言葉でもいいんです
正しい見解なんかはあるわけじゃないんです
もう無数に見解あるだけで
一人の人間がたくさん見解を持っている
人間 10人だったらどれぐらい見解を持ってるか分かったもんじゃないんです
それも当てにならない
次から次へと変わる だからその中の一つを選ぶということはありえない
不可能 ダメです だから見解がないことなんです
見解がないとは 貪瞋痴がないことなんです
貪瞋痴がある限り見解があるんです
真理に達したら 生命ではなく聖者なんです
だから真偽を問うといて
調べて真に達した人はもう人間じゃないんです
人間とは存在欲ある生命だからね
生命組織ですけど 生命組織ですけど
認識機能もあるんだけど
存在欲はないんです だから聖者と言うんです
次 あの最後に あの真理って何ですかと
今日私は時間ないんだから飛ばしたところいっぱいありましてね
インド人がいろんな宗教を持っていたんですよ
死んでから梵天に生まれる人いるんだと
もう一人の宗教は いえ
死んだら人は転生するんだと
魂が転生して終わりますよと
もう一人の宗教は いえ
転生でも回転であると
魂は死んだら壊れますよと
体が支えているんだと
いろんな宗教があったんです
また 哲学的に宇宙と魂が無限ですか？有限ですか？宇宙と魂は
生命はという いわゆる体と魂が別々ですか？同じものですか？といろんな
もう 62と言ってもあるはあるわ
今現代 我々生きてる世界を見ても
唯一の神はブラフマですか
ラーマですか シヴァですかとかね
あるいはアッラーですか
イエホワですか イエス
どうか むちゃくちゃいっぱいあるんだからね
そこで そういうすっぴての見解
存在欲です 一つも素晴らしい尊いものではないんです
どんな宗教の本でも聖なる本やと言ったらあかん
ゴミです 本当に くだらないことばっかり書いてる
大事なポイントもありますよ
人間や植樹しましょうとかね
あれやこれやとかね 人を助けましょうよとかね
キリスト教でもね まあ苦しんでる人々を助けましょうよと派手に言ってますよ
いい考えですよ でも私は
気に入らん 神は全知全能でね
慈悲を持ってるんだったら
なんで不幸な人間を作ったんですかと
だからキリスト教の方々にボランティア活動するために不幸な人間が存在しないと
それ自体残酷な考えでしょうに
だからそれは置いといて
不幸な人を助けることはいいことなんです
だから だからといって
宗教を言っていることは素晴らしいということはないんです
仏教はあまり気にしない
全てゴミやということにしてるんです
見解そのものは貪瞋痴が生まれ作ったものだからゴミですと
だからこの素晴らしい 3000年前
4000年前  5000年前でもいいんだけど
出来上がった聖書聖典類は
まあただの存在欲のために書かれているんです
ヴェーダ聖典は明らかに存在欲のために書かれているんです
仏教聖典というのは お釈迦様が喋ったものをまとめた編集していただけで
学問的に 別の聖典定点という扱いはいりません
勉強するテキストです
そういうわけで 真理って何なのかと
先入観 感情をバイパスして
ありのままに観察します
我々は すべての見解はゴミやと気持ちで始まるんです
瞑想実践 ただ 歩ける 運ぶ
あれやこれやと観察する
何も入れません 一切は無常・苦・無我で
因縁によって生じて消える流れだと発見する
それが真理です いわゆる見解は成り立たんことが真理です
すべて無常で流れるんだと
因果法則だと 見解は俗世間的にあるが
真理として成り立たないんです
見解はあるんです 人間は食事としてご飯を食べなくちゃいけない
草食べてはいけません
藁食べてはいけませんよ
牛が食べてるんだからといって
それは俗世間の考えですね
間違ってないんです 人間はペットとして猛毒のヘビを飼ってはいけませんとかね
それはそれでいいんです
それは俗世間で存在欲のための世界なんですね
それは否定しません 交通ルールは守るべきです
否定しません それは存在欲のためのことであって
最終的な真理ではないんです
ですから 見解は俗世間的にあるが
真理として成り立たないんです
真理は無常 苦 無我です
はい 終わりです どうもありがとうございます
時間どれぐらい行ったかどうか分かりませんでしたが
先生 ありがとうございました
すいません 時間が過ぎてしまいましたので
今日はちょっと質疑応答の部分は割愛させていただきたいと思います
最後に皆さんで回向の文を唱えて終了したいと思います
合掌してください 回向の文
仏法僧の三宝に大拝敬し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱が得られますように
サンピテワジャンツーサンバルーポウィナッセットマーテーヴァッとアンタラヨシュケーディーガユコーバヴァーサッブマンガランラッカーンサッブデヴァタサッブバ
ンダヌーバーヴェーナサンバダンマヌーバーヴェーナサッブサンガーヌーバーヴェーナサダー蘇ってバワントゥテーアビロードナシーリーッシェニッチャンマンダパチャイ
ノーチャットルーダンマヴァッダンティアユバンノーシュカンバランアイラーローディサンプティサンガサンプティミーヴェッチアトーニンバーナサンプティイミナーデーサミンジュエトゥ
サードゥ サードゥ サードゥ
はい どうもありがとうございます